hello patronage exits greg alba here i'm
john we're gonna watch a trailer today
not an actual trailer this week
suggestion Justice League reacts to
Avengers Infinity Ward trailer I've had
this trailer in this video bookmark for
a while waiting for waiting for the
right time before we do that but we just
did an unboxing video at our patreon our
top patron Gareth hood sent us over some
Christmas gifts and since this is
Avengers and justice Lee combined I'll
share some of them here
you got this Danno shirt yeah right here
this is like John and I will switch off
wearing it a Thanos toy hecka posters
yeah all right all right
I'm the Marvel end of the spectrum it's
got the marble ones and the DC ones are
gonna be on our wall and 2018 bad boy
Gareth thank you once more that videos
on our patron right now also guys he
didn't ask us to do it but check out
this guy's Instagram we call him our
international man of mystery because is
our highest patron and we have no idea
what the hell he even does for a living
yet he's sending us all these freaking
yeah thank you Gareth all I'm at the
Gareth head on Instagram I follow him he
follows him and the real rejects
Instagram awesome so you should too
hopefully you get better soon Yousef
he's dying he's dying
unless you're on something we need to
talk about and I don't think you're
gonna like it
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
does
[Music]
you're in that format the trailer so
listen gentlemen I believe it's time to
reconsider the viability of the tip
[Music]
[Music]
you know kind of reactant
I feel like the joke of it is I don't
think they're leaving and go fight with
the Avengers I think the joke of it is
that oh the Avengers is gonna be better
yeah I'm one of the few just probably
went out on YouTube was like I love
Justice League that's me not saying all
that I'm like Justice League but I feel
like that's the joke of the video is
like in terms of spicing in with a
specific scene I thought that was one of
its best ones I've seen ones of like
Avengers reacts to Justice League
trailer finding a specific scene this
moment is unique one itself yeah I'll
get to make a little comment there all
together they're all looking at ya you
get the reaction shots and everything
yeah yeah so that was well spliced
together I still think my favorite fake
reaction one is still Matthew
McConaughey it's hard to edit something
like this together yeah it's very hard
to put something like this together and
I think I think this guy did a great job
dr. machaca I feel like I've seen other
ones was he the guy who did the Avengers
react to Justice League 1 - that was
well done that was funny that was funny
here's one thing I will say that the
watching this video got me to note one
thing that people always say about the
DC EU is that they at least have great
music and there are films or standout
original scores the Avengers I feel like
that song will finally be like the
Avenger so I guess it's always been
there but it's the first time I think
well we really feel that song I feel
like I probably be right about that cuz
every time I hear it I'm like oh yeah
they have they have some kind to them
okay and each time I hear it it gets a
little more ingrained into my memory and
it goes well with the trailer it does it
makes you feel super epic and it makes
the stakes feel really high yeah I feel
like when they composed it for the first
Avengers it was for when they would do
infinity horror you want this theme to
percolate over many films and finally
ready for its full possession guys you
can subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell you could
follow us on patreon it's like a second
youtube channel be
come a patronage ektu die